[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la gorge et spectaculaire elle attire
des touristes de partout et laurent est
un des villages les plus bucolique de
l'ontario c'est aussi le coeur de la
lutte pour l'eau potable dans la
province signe de la résistance contre
le géant nestlé
on retrouve un peu partout ces affiches
et ses rubans bleus je suis contre et
une industrie qui veut l'idée notre cher
pour pour vendre l'eau ailleurs et c'est
ça qui arriverait si on permet à l'as
fait de revenir s'installer dans cette
guerre de l'eau a commencé lorsque
nestlé a acheté pour une somme non
divulguée ce site désaffecté où se
trouve l'ancien puits de la mine d'oak
brook world company le puits a une
capacité de production de plus d'un
million de litres par jour
le comté de wellington qui englobe le
village de laura a aussi soumis une
offre
mais après celle déposée par nestlé la
multinationale a accepté de nous
rencontrer près du site de son usine
d'embouteillage et d'un autre puits
d'une capacité de 3 millions et demi de
litres par jour
oui on ne soutient qu'elle teste le
niveau de la nappe phréatique à chaque
heure car elle a à coeur la protection
de l'eau dans la région et que
l'exploitation du puits mais de broca et
laura ne serait qu'une source
d'approvisionnement d'appoint lors des
arrêts de production pour de l'entretien
annuel ici alston justin ouailles
le groupe save our rejette ces arguments
et croit plutôt à une expansion des
opérations de nestlé dans la région un
développement inacceptable dans une
région en plein boom démographique et où
le besoin en eau potable explose selon
eux la province prédit d'ailleurs que la
population doublera à 50 mille résidents
d'ici 20 ans aujourd'hui on a des
populations qui augmente qui augmente
qui augmente la des ressources qui qui
deviennent de plus en plus restreinte
pourquoi comme vous donnerai tout ça
pour rien la question des frais liés aux
permis d'embouteillage revient à l'avant
plan ils sont 2 500 3 dollars par
million de litres en ontario et de 70
dollars par million de lettres au québec
l'ontario a imposé un moratoire qui
prendra fin en janvier prochain sur
l'ouverture de nouvelles usines
d'embouteillage d'eau et sur
l'agrandissement des installations
existantes en raison du moratoire nestlé
n'a pas le droit d'effectuer des tests
aux plumes et de broc et encore moins
d'y puiser de l'eau pour de
l'embouteillage le plus inquiétant c'est
que nenni c'est une énorme compagnie
avec des poches très profondes et avec
des avocats et etsaut et nécessite une
compagnie qui est très patient
qu'adviendra-t-il du moratoire ce sera
au prochain gouvernement ontarien de
trancher l'élection de la semaine
prochaine revêt donc une importance
particulière dans cette région
pittoresque ici philippe leblanc
radio-canada et laura